for the majority of my childhood the
holidays were the scariest time of year
for me because my family was cursed this
is that story it all started when I was
five years old my mom's Sunday School
class was raising money for a charity so
she had our class make Christmas
ornaments using white glue and glitter
all of the ornaments were bought by
churchgoers except for one ornament this
ornament was supposed to be a bell with
a peace sign in it very Christmasy but
it actually ended up looking more like
Darth Vader not very Christmasy well my
mom felt bad so she bought it herself we
should have been suspicious that no one
wanted this ornament from that holiday
season on we always hung that ornament
on our tree duan do like without a
second thought or like nevertheless we
hung the ornament on our tree would have
a second thought oddly enough we started
having really bad luck around
Thanksgiving and Christmas know I've
tried to look right at the camera
say hi we're trying to record a video
about a Christmas curse we're just
starting to talk about the curse element
of it and the camera keeps shutting off
like something doesn't want this story
to be told I'm not gonna say anything
else I'm just telling you what's
happening every year every year we could
count on something bad happening
for example our dog passed away the day
after Thanksgiving my grandpa had to
have emergency surgery my cat passed
away the day after Christmas my dad was
actually misdiagnosed with a heart
attack and ended up having to have
emergency back surgery we lived in New
Jersey bad stuff happened
we moved across the country to Oregon
bad stuff continued to happen so now
it's 2004 and I'm in seventh grade my
mom's parents my grandparents had come
into town for the holidays when I was
growing up a modern term to describe my
mom and grandma would probably be
Pinterest Queens the whole house always
looked beautiful
there were Garland's and twinkle lights
and it was like living in a movie
amongst these beautiful decorations was
that weird Darth Vader ornament cut to
Christmas morning I'm awake and I'm
ready to unwrap what I was hoping was a
fashion Polly bedroom set so my sister
and I were raised not to leave our rooms
until mom or dad told us to come
downstairs for Christmas they just
wanted some peace and quiet in the
morning before all hell broke loose I'm
sitting in bed anxiously awaiting to
demolish some pretty wrapping paper when
I hear my mom yell from down the stairs
now this should have been an exciting
moment because it meant Christmas was
ready but it was a different kind of
yell it sounded more like a cry of pain
then I heard her shout don't come down
the stairs followed by a bunch of bangs
and fun
[Music]
sorry to interrupt the video but the
reason you're looking at me right now
and not Jacky is because when I went to
edit this footage altogether half of the
footage was missing could this be some
sort of technical error maybe could it
be my fault
also maybe it's really weird this has
never happened to me before so we're
gonna have to meet up again and shoot
the rest of this video I'm getting super
creeped out I'm not too worried but my
mom's really nervous right now I told
her that we had to reshoot some stuff
and she goes no you shouldn't do it you
just shouldn't do it let's do it
so it's Christmas and I am
uncontrollably excited which is not a
good combination for following
directions when I hear don't come down
the stairs I immediately leave my room
to go see what's happening I see my mom
and my grandma both lying at the bottom
of the stairs apparently my mom had been
carrying a pile of presents down the
stairs when she tripped over the cat and
fell then her mother my grandma came
running out to see what happened that's
when mom yelled don't come down the
stairs the series of bangs and thuds
belonged to Grandma who had fallen down
the stairs attempting to rush to her
daughter's aid so I run back to my bed
holding back tears because I was so
scared and I had no idea what was going
on at some point an ambulance came and
took my mom and grandma to the hospital
while my sister and I were taken to a
family friend's house that was a weird
day it wasn't until later that night
that we got to go home and see mom
but grandma was still in the hospital my
mom had messed up her ankle really bad
it was completely black and about three
times it's normal size
we learned that grandma had broke into
her femur which is the bone in your
thigh and she needed emergency surgery
and ended up in the hospital for six
weeks later later that night we finally
got to open presents but I didn't even
care that it was Christmas anymore I was
just so thankful but nothing worse had
happened
so a year passes it's the holiday season
again and my mom my sister and I are
decorating the tree
my sister pulls out that weird Darth
Vader II looking ornament out of nowhere
my sister decides that Darth Vader is
the reason for all of our bad luck and
we shouldn't hang him on the tree even
though I always thought it was a little
weird it was just an ornament we argued
for a little bit but she insisted that
we not hang it on the tree however I was
a very bratty younger sister and I
wanted to prove her wrong later that
night when she wasn't around I hung the
ornament on the back of the tree so she
wouldn't see it
fast-forward to Christmas Day that year
we had a wonderful breakfast I got all
the presents I hoped for dinner was a
spectacular feast and it was overall a
really great day after our family
friends had left I was getting ready for
bed and my stomach started hurting my
mom and I decided that it was probably
just because I ate a lot of dinner and
that seemed to add up but the pain kept
getting worse I'm lying in bed crying
from the pain and my parents are
frantically googling the symptoms to
find out what's wrong with me for the
second Christmas in a row an ambulance
comes to my house but this time I'm the
one being taken away we got to the
hospital and I was so scared because a
handful of doctors had come to diagnose
me and none of them could figure out
what was wrong however every single one
of them did ask me is it possible that
you're pregnant
what I was 13 years old I haven't even
kissed a boy yet hearing that question
over and over again just made me so
frustrated I was in pain and I wanted to
know what was wrong they decided to give
me an ultrasound anyway
this revealed that my appendix had
ruptured I was immediately whisked away
to surgery cut to me waking up in a room
I didn't recognize which is not very
comforting but the pain was finally gone
I was only in the hospital for three
days the nurses all called me the poster
child of appendectomy eventually I went
home and I just laid in bed for another
day or two as I'm recovering I think to
myself how did I get roped into this
family curse what did I do to deserve
this no no there's there's no way my
sister was right that ornament that
strange weird little Darth Vader
ornament my sister said don't put it on
the tree what did I do
I put it on the tree did I do this to
myself regardless I knew what needed to
be done my mom my sister and I decided
we were gonna bury him we burned sage we
put an angel statue on top of him and we
surrounded it with a circle of salt I'm
glad to say my family did not have the
same bad luck after that we had beaten
this curse once and for all we had no
idea this strange seemingly innocent
Darth Vader ornament had been wreaking
havoc on our lives for years a couple
years after the last incident we moved
out of that house so I honestly don't
know what's become of Darth Vader but if
you live in a suburb of Portland Oregon
and you find a weird glittery thing
while digging in your garden first
comment below and then burn it watch
we're gonna put it up on YouTube and and
the whole like Internet's gonna crash
[Music]
[Music]